jonah how you doing hey how are you i'm
good thanks
um so i have a bit of an interesting
question
so this one might be a little
contentious but i really want your
opinion on this all right um so i've
been
i've been putting together like i've
been talking with some of my girlfriends
some of them are older they're in their
40s some of them are younger so they're
in their like mid-20s
and what i'm noticing is more and more
um they're just turning away from even
getting into relationships they're not
interested in dating they're not even
interested some of them are actually not
even interested in men anymore so
they're kind of going the other way
um some of them are just kind of going
you know what i just i can't be bothered
with this i just want to travel and i'll
get a dog
so
and then when i started looking at some
of the content that was online
i started kind of noticing that the
conversations were more
not that you do it but more about either
bashing women or
or criticizing women or talking about
how fat women are which i do believe is
a problem
um
but there wasn't a lot of talk about
romance there wasn't a lot of talk about
how to be an interesting person how to
be sexually seductive to a woman how to
be appealing to a woman how to how to
actually have relationships
and when i tried talking to a guy friend
of mine who said he wanted to he wanted
to get better at having relationships
with women
and i tried to give him some pointers
said men don't need advice from women
about women
so what my question is
if if men don't need advice from women
about how to deal with women and what
women like and what actually turns women
on
and they can only get that advice from
men and women can only get advice on men
from other men because advice from other
women is not valid
where exactly are women in the
conversation when it comes to
heterosexual relationships between men
and women
you've said a lot of things and you've
asked quite quite a few questions in
that
statement
look um
so
let's start with this so why are your
friends not wanting to date guys you
said they're somewhere in their 20s and
early 30s
summers go as late as into their mid-40s
and they're all with the exception of
one or two that are kind of the
blue-haired you know
you know whatever people
um
they are smoke shows because we all kind
of have the same lifestyle pilates
exercising boxes are all very
we're very much we like our looks right
so
are they career women or
like boss girls
they're not really boss girls they're
bought here's the thing they're boss
girls because they have to be they're
boss girls because the men aren't
stepping up to the challenge so for
example
uh see okay so let me just stop you for
a sec so you're saying men aren't
stepping up to the challenge in one
breath but in a prior breath you're also
saying that
um you know these guys aren't romantic
or they don't know how to you know like
romance women you know sort of thing and
it's like
you know
i have a problem with that because
guys that subscribe to
like the soul mate myth and like the
whole lance romance stuff like i'll tell
you like when i went out on my first uh
date with my first girlfriend
i can't remember if somebody told me
this or i saw it in some stupid magazine
that somebody handed me but it was like
at the start of the date you got to give
her this color flower and at the end of
the day you got to give her this flower
and it means this that and the other
thing and we've all tried that stuff
well not we've all but i'm just kind of
you know speaking for myself but the
guys that are in my tribe the guys that
get it the guys that have like plentiful
access and are the mate selectors when
it comes to dating they get it and they
know that stuff doesn't work and they
know that the stuff that i talk about
does work and it's not like
we're not
like we're ice cold or anything like
that
um i mean you know if you were to ask my
chick she would say none of those things
but it's
it's just having
a solid leadership frame and the problem
that a lot of women have today these
women that are like you know they have
to be boss girls in their career to do
what they're doing and they don't want
to deal with men is that
they're not able or willing to enter a
man's frame and comply
may i just uh i i do disagree with that
um we all kind of have very traditional
values and when i say we we all just
kind of work because we have to it's
just because you know we're we're girls
we like certain kinds of shoes we like
eating at certain restaurants so you
have to work to maintain that
um just a personal standard
um what we're finding is a lot of the
guys like even when you go on dates with
these guys and a lot of the guys are
coming from the internet they conform
sentences they can't have basic
conversation a lot of them don't read a
lot of them have no interest no hobbies
don't go to the gym if they do go to the
gym that's
all they do
so why are they going out with them then
well it's basically going out with
losers well that's the thing like it
gets to the point where um you don't
really realize that these people are
like that until you kind of go on the
first date or even after the first
conversation you're like okay might be
something here
but
what work what is happening more and
more is that there seems to be this kind
of contentiousness when it comes to
pleasing and satisfying the other person
as and i'm seeing it more on the men's
side men seem to think that every single
woman is out to get them if you're
pretty then you obviously don't have any
money you are trying to take advantage
of him so you don't have anything of
your own what uh city do you and your
friends live in uh we're in your city oh
toronto
well
toronto's a big-ass city and there's a
lot of weird-ass people in there i'll be
honest with you you know i did a lot of
dating down there
um
look the like
here's what i'm seeing a lot of right
you know from the guy's perspective and
moff just hit on it in the chat you can
blame feminism for pretty much all of
that is that women have been told to go
and chase the degree they don't need no
man go and go and work and then they
hear all these songs about being a
hashtag boss girl and bad [ __ ] and all
that kind of stuff
and like let's be honest jenna like you
know you get together with them and
they're like yeah one bad [ __ ] and then
all sort of thing and it's like we don't
need no man cert it's like okay well
when you start from that position
then like even i
with the game that i have dealing with a
trick like that on a date if i were to
tell her you know something like i don't
know like i'll meet you at eight o'clock
at this place and she's like oh well
that's too far i'm not gonna go there or
why not on this nate and then she starts
giving me a hard time i have zero
patience for any of that it's like no
that's that's what we've uh that's what
we're doing and you're gonna be there
and when you show up you're going to
wear that black dress i told you to from
that picture
right i want you to wiggle a little bit
when you walk in too right so you kind
of play with a little bit you know you
kind of tease them a little bit
but you make sure that they're following
your lead
and what you'll find with a lot of these
women or guys find
you know guys like me anyway
is they'll find that they don't want to
comply you know they they want a strong
masculine dude and you called in months
ago and we were talking about
yellowstone like the casey's and the
rips right like
like you and your girlfriends probably
watch a show and you probably drool over
casey and rip right
right yeah fair enough okay so
when a guy like rip shows up
and it's like this is what we're doing
about no no no it's going to happen on
this state and we're going to do it on
this and it's like that sort of thing
they don't even want to comply with that
so they say that they want that but they
won't work with it
that i do i do disagree because i have
dated i have actually dated men like rip
the only reason that the relationship
didn't work out is just because of
distance we ended up moving apart but
men like that when you are i see the
women that you're talking about jenna
though like i like i've dated them i i
see them when i go out and and these
chicks are like you know they think that
they're the bomb they're
30s 40s whatever they work out they do
yoga pilates exactly like you know you
described right and
they're jacked they got shoulders and
abs and all those sort of stuff but do
they know how to cook do they know how
to like please a guy do they know how to
be pleasant and agreeable yes
this is it this isn't just about in all
in all and the problem is is that
they're they're picking losers is what
it boils down to
okay i mean if they're hanging out with
guys that don't know how to conversation
or haven't read a book in like 10 years
or something like that
then they're picking losers right like
don't date losers you know it's as
simple as that oh well i want to date
the good-looking guy then but you know
he's going to cheat on me oh well
what are you going to do you know a guy
with options might happen to have a
couple of plates spinning right now too
and then are you guys okay with the
women having options as well absolutely
not
okay
it what's what's good for the goose is
not good for the gander
if if she's going to date me and then
she's like hey rich where do we stand i
really dig your vibe blah blah blah not
sure stuff cool
but we're not going to poison the well
you need to be exclusive
whether i choose to be exclusive to her
or not is entirely up to me at that time
monogamy is a choice for men
and it cannot be enforced on them
right so in some cases some of these you
know bad [ __ ] that are all like oh
you can't just find a guy and i'm just
going to switch over to the other side
and deal with girls or get a dog or
whatever you know like that's your
solution
then
look
guys that are that are that are high
value that are top shelf that are
willing to be monogamous that that chews
it you know with a good girl you better
treat him like a god i'm telling you
right now because guys like that are
rare
that's it's oh my gosh i honestly wish
that i could have this conversation a
little longer i know i have to go but
it's
the re the reality that
is very very different okay
i'll tell you what
send me an email and let's set up a
unplugged alpha show where you and your
girlfriends hop on with me
and i'll give you guys that time all
right i wonder if bethany would be up
for that okay yeah sure okay all right
great let's do it all right thank you
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you